et se rendra à Istanbul ce soir a priori
au Pavillon va des tines sur la rive
asiatique c'est l'une des résidences de
réception
bilatérale qui est prévue après une
rencontre multilatéral entre la
délégation et une conférence de presse
est prévue c'est dans le l'agenda
officiel du président turc à 21h heure
de Turquie c'est-à-dire 20h heure de
Paris donc les deux hommes vont parler
de la guerre en Ukraine c'est ce qui a
été précisé par l'agence officielle
tueur canadeloup et de cet accord sur le
corridor céréalier qui a été signé ici à
Istanbul en juillet dernier qui a permis
comme vous le savez l'exportation de
millions de tonnes de de blé Ukrainiens
depuis les ports Ukrainiens sur les
marchés comme à chaque fois la Russie
est traîne des pieds et a même déclaré
il y a quelques jours qu'elle ne voyait
aucune raison de renouveler cet accord
qui arrive à expiration comme vous
l'avez dit le 17 juillet donc ce sera à
la Turquie d'essayer et de faire
médiation il y a peut-être un autre
sujet dont le président Zelinski voudra
discuter avec rejet de hyperdoğan vous
le savez depuis le début de la guerre en
Ukraine la Turquie
essaie de rester neutre et de faire la
médiatrice entre
les deux pays mais elle est aussi
accusée en plus de ne pas participer aux
sanctions occidentales contre l'économie
russe de participer à une sorte de
reconstitution de la chaîne logistique
militaire de la Russie en Turquie et il
y a eu cet article du Wall Street
Journal paru il y a quelques jours cette
enquête qui révèle que depuis mai des
cargo russes frappés par des sanctions
occidentales parce que soupçonné
justement de participer à une
reconstitution d'une chaîne logistique
militaire secrète en Russie et bien que
c'est cargorus se sont arrêtés dans des
escales Turcs au moins une centaine de
fois depuis mai donc c'était un sujet
que vous les divers zen qui voudra
aborder puis enfin on peut
imaginer que le président turc assura de
nouveau comme il l'a fait de nombreuses
fois dans le passé du soutien de son
pays la Turquie à une éventuelle
adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'OTAN vous
l'avez dit le grand sommet de le temps
s'ouvre à Vénus dans quelques jours